seven nominations tonight
if you sweep the big four categories you
will be the second woman and the second
youngest to ever do that
can you wrap your brain around that
moment
i am just like so genuinely excited just
be here and watch all the performers if
i won one that would just be like
something i couldn't even fathom so
olivia you're doing all this at 19 years
old right now let's just stop for a
second she's 19 and she's doing all this
i feel very lucky to be able to do this
yes okay so give me a rundown because
you do look like the bell of the ball
amazing is this are these all like hand
yeah yeah they're like little crystals
um it's vivian westwood and i i love
that designer so okay let me just stop
because that's a moment a vivian
westwood moment thank you when you saw
it did they sketch it for you how did
this whole concept come up yes oh my
gosh it's like a custom dress which is
so crazy i felt so fancy getting a dress
design for me for tonight but uh yeah i
feel really confident and that's all i
can ask for i'm so excited for tonight
there's been such a great reception for
driving home to you how's that and how
how good is that yeah it feels amazing
we worked really hard on the film and
i said it before but i'm going on tour
actually like literally the second we
finished the grammys i'm going on tour
and so i wanted to give my fans who
maybe um wouldn't be able to make it to
a concert uh something that they could
watch for a you know a little bit of new
content so i'm happy that we did that
now are you performing tonight too
you're performing tonight too all right
so stepping on that grammy stage what's
that moment going to be like when you oh
my god i'm going to be so nervous but
hopefully it'll go off without a hitch
um yeah it's crazy i've just watched the
grammys religiously since i was so young
and just to be here and perform up on
that stage is just
such an honor the grammys are about
those dream collaborations who's still
out there who's out there for you that
you say i've got to make this happen oh
my gosh i mean so many people um brenda
carla is performing tonight and she's a
big inspiration i think she's incredible
songwriter so i'm excited to meet her
would be fire
good luck tonight olivia and thank you
for stopping by you look forward
[Music]